there's no doubt that dove cameron is
going places but even doug's biggest
fans will be surprised to remember
some of the roles that got her to where
she is now here we go again with the
name
definite tendency to obsess do people
ever tell you that known for her disney
channel presents with roles and
descendants
liv and maddie and austin and ally doug
cameron got her big break when she was
just 16 years old but disney is not all
she's done
you won't believe how versatile she is
in these lesser-known roles you probably
forgot all about from villains to voice
acting
dove has done it all and we can't wait
to see what she does next
i think any kind of action girl is
that's my type of girl before she became
a disney superstar dove cameron had a
number of guest spots on some pretty
major tv series
dub's big break came when she played
holly hermiker on a little show called
shameless
you might not have known it since the
role marks a huge departure from her
later disney roles dubs character was
much more risque than you'd think
can we watch an r-rated movie shameless
follows the dysfunctional gallagher
family as they struggle to get by
dubs character holly is a bad girl type
who shows interest in one of the
gallagher sons but things don't exactly
work out he rejects her advances and she
ends up running away
quite a juicy role for dove to make her
debut in and who knows
maybe if deb hadn't established her
serious acting chops in smaller roles on
major shows like this one then maybe she
wouldn't have been cast in liv and
maddie now that would have been a shame
what did you just say we have different
birthdays next up dove had an
awesome guest run on marvel's agents of
shield in 2018
dove appeared as the mysterious ruby
hail on agents of shield she had a whole
complex arc on season 5 of the superhero
show where she played one of the main
villains of the season
known as the destroyer of worlds ruby
was raised from birth to be a human
weapon for hydra
leaving her stunted and full of hatred
especially towards daisy johnson
you know i could have beaten daisy
johnson today if you hadn't forced her
to run but despite the darkness
of the role it's so much fun to see dove
let loose as an unhinged villain
and all-powerful assassin because it's
the kind of role she hadn't really had
the chance to inhabit before and we're
sure the fight scenes were so much fun
to shoot
watching quake face off against ruby has
got to be one of the most epic parts of
the whole season
daisy johnson
where is she this indie action comedy
from 2015 saw dove acting alongside big
names like haley steinfeld sophie turner
jessica elba and the one and only samuel
l jackson
barely lethal follows hayley steinfeld's
character known as agent 83
a government-trained spy assassin who
leaves behind her life of espionage to
become a regular teenage girl she
changes her name to megan and enrolls as
an exchange student taken in by the
larsen family
in the movie dove plays liz larson their
sarcastic teenage daughter who at first
wants nothing to do with megan
put these on and just not to talk to me
and she absolutely nails the savage
sarcastic quips but watching her go from
antagonistic to forming a sisterly bond
with steinfeld's megan
is truly the heart of the movie and we
can't help but think of dove's time as
maddie on liv and maddie prepared her
somewhat for this
role go get him not without you
dev also had a supporting role in the
netflix movie dumplin
this coming of age dramedy starring
jennifer aniston and up and comer
danielle mcdonald came out in 2018
adapted from the novel of the same name
the movie is about will dumplin dixon
the plus-sized teenage daughter of a
former pageant queen who blazes a trail
through the beauty pageant scene in her
small texas town
dove played becca the pageant
front-runner and classical beauty queen
who competes with dumplin for the
affections of the town hunk beau larson
and he is such a cutie am i right
we've all heard dove's beautiful singing
voice before but here she gets to show
off her dance moves and put on an
adorable southern accent even though her
role in the film is small
dove still shines and makes a big
impression your moment is so good at
just everything else who doesn't love a
musical
better yet who doesn't love a live tv
musical it's all the magic of broadway
but from the comfort of your own home
and 2016 hairspray live was no exception
but it was made even better because our
fave descendant star got to shine in it
something you might not have known about
dove cameron is that she's actually a
prolific
stage performer as well having starred
in productions of les miserables
mamma mia and clueless the musical so
she was a natural fit for hairspray
[Applause]
duff played the role of amber von
tussell the ambitious mean girl
in this star-studded live tv special of
the musical hairspray alongside ariana
grande kristen chenoweth and jennifer
hudson
we hate to say it but we think dove even
outsang ariana
keep the stupid crown amber i have my
heart set on something a lot more
important
this next one is definitely overlooked
way back in 2012 in only her second
television role dove guest starred on
the mentalist
in the episode devil's cherry the
mentalist follows patrick jane played by
simon baker
a so-called mentalist who uses his
observational skills to help solve
crimes
in a bizarre series of events jane
encounters a mysterious girl claiming to
be his deceased daughter charlotte
played by none other than dove cameron
i had a daughter named charlotte
i know this was one of dove's earliest
roles on tv but she was lucky enough to
get to work closely with the main star
playing charlotte jane a character who
only appears to jane in hallucinations
throughout the episode
made for a really interesting
performance and dynamic between the
characters even as her career was just
burgeoning dove chose some fantastic
roles that no doubt helped put her on
the map
i mean we're dead gone
you need to start dealing with that
interestingly dev also starred in
another show involving criminal cases
only this time it's a comedy that spoofs
police procedurals just like the
mentalist angie tribeca
is known for its long list of amazing
guest stars lisa kudrow
is just so funny one of whom was dove
cameron
in a bit of a departure from her usual
projects dove appeared in season four of
this quirky comedy created by nancy and
steve carell of the office fame
the show stars rashida jones as angie
tribeca a veteran police detective who
goes undercover at a high school glee
club in the episode glitch perfect
duff cameron guest start is grace one of
the students and glee club members not
only can dove kill it in dramatic roles
but she's also got some seriously funny
comedic chops
if you thought dub couldn't be any more
talented just wait till we tell you
about her voiceover work dove lent her
voice to play the iconic spider-man
character gwen stacy
aka spider-gwen aka ghost spider she
started voicing gwen stacy on the
animated tv show
ultimate spider-man and i'm trying to be
a hero like you two
she's since returned to the role of gwen
stacy as ghost spider in a number of
marvel rising shorts over the past few
years
fun fact dev also sang the theme song
for the first marvel rising
secret warriors and while this is only
speculation dove may even be in line to
play spider gwen in the live-action mcu
in an interview with yahoo entertainment
dove said she'd love to play gwen stacy
having already voiced the character we
think she'd be perfect opposite
tom holland spider-man what do you think
i would love it if she was like an equal
match
but spider-man isn't the only thing dove
has lent her voice to did you know she
also did the voice of ella in the angry
birds movie too
a sequel to the angry birds movie based
on the infamous game
angry birds 2 sees the birds having to
join forces with the pigs when the bird
and piggy islands are both threatened by
a common enemy
the eagles ella is described as a
workaholic type
a bird but she's also super independent
and opinionated
yeah you know what maybe it's your
eyebrows my eyebrows are fine
apparently ella was originally supposed
to look very different but after dove
cameron was cast in the role the
producers decided it would be funny to
change her into a dove we're glad
because her character design is
fittingly adorable
um are you mad last but not least dove
also appears as a recurring character on
the lodge which premiered on the disney
channel uk
in 2016 while duff broke out as the
disney starlet on liv and maddie and the
descendants
film series this disney uk series is a
lesser known gem that you might not have
known about the lodge follows
fifteen-year-old skye who moves to
northern ireland with her father to take
over a hotel called the north star
dove played the character jess in four
episodes of the show where she played a
competitive biker
and friend of main character sean played
by none other than thomas daughtry
that's right
dove's descendants co-star and irl
boyfriend and we have to say
their chemistry is undeniable on screen
as well as off
yeah sean actually cut me up here once
pretty bad
at just 24 years old dove cameron has
already had a prolific career
she even has two films slated for 2021
called
isaac and vengeance we can't wait to see
more from this exciting young star
did you know about some of dove's
lesser-known roles leave a comment below
and don't forget to subscribe for more
awesome content from the things
thanks for watching
you